there aren't no longer many ways to
leave Russia
but this is one of them the border with
Finland at valimar a three-hour drive
from Saint Petersburg
and where the numbers departing seem to
be increasing in the wake of President
Vladimir Putin's partial mobilization of
the Russian people
there has been more traffic Crossing
from Russia to Finland since Wednesday
evening there are no particular
restrictions with an external border to
the Schengen zone so we performed
thorough checks most people are
traveling into Finland on tourist visas
one of those is Dimitri medioshko an
engineer from some Petersburg on his way
to Helsinki and then Sri Lanka where he
hopes to be safe from a call-up to fight
the war in Ukraine when did you decide
to to leave Russia two days ago
because of the mobilization yes
I don't have a list of for mobilization
but are you scared how did you get
through the Border uh oh good good no
questions so always good just go and
uh leave Russia
border police said that 6 000 Russians
came into Finland through this Crossing
alone on Thursday double the number of a
week earlier
Friday was another busy day with queues
stretching back some 400 meters
Elena grafova has been commuting over
the Border since February
she doesn't believe most people are in
any great rush to leave I don't feel
Panic around people here on the borders
so it's very very easy very calm not
like
some people think it is
later calm turned into almost total
quiet
as evening draws in here there's just a
few cars left from the long queues of
the morning most of the Russians who've
tried to get across this border seem to
have been successful
those could be the lucky ones reports in
The Finnish media say ministers are
working on a plan to get around the
principles of the Schengen agreement on
freedom of movement
by claiming that finland's acceptance of
Russian tourists is damaging its
International relationships
Polaris Al Jazeera valimar on the
Finland Russia border